allez les cherry dans les 12 coups de
midi on a fait la rencontre d'un
candidat qui a un tatouage est à un
moment il a jean luc reichmann qui lui
demande sur quelle partie du corps il
l'a fait regardez bien sa réponse qui
est à toi ici jean-paul toi t'as quoi
comme tatouage en un pelage et des
écritures lala sur le pied sur le pli
chaque année quoi sur le piéger le chi
ça s'appelle c'est le sérénité
opportunités détermination chi oui le
schiste ainsi les champs heureusement
des amis sur le long week-end il en a
plein mais énormément moi je n'ai une
quinzaine en quinzaine de tatouage mais
j'ai su les places et pour pas qu'on les
voit enfin si vous alliez vous allez
encore une jolie peau c'est dommage un
bas bien sûr et elle a raison elle
travaille elle travaillait chez estée
lauder en artistique mami est très jolie
peau c'est dommage que j'allais faire un
gag défaite
je rappelle que c'est des métaux lourds
en l'état toile c'est vrai tu sais que
j'ai voulu faire le visage et on m'a
retenu de le faire je le serai pas vous
savez est consciente j'avais failli vous
faire tatouer le visage match aja
j'adore j'adore les mais votre visage
est fan de crem estée lauder ou les
bottes quoi bas un petit un petit
papillon un petit truand sur le visage
discret ouais ouais j'aime beaucoup moi
je voulais faire une merguez ici ça me
dirait très bien bah oui mais france
aussi franchement oui et toi t'as pas de
tatouage away et toi j'en ai sur le dos
sur l'épaule j'ai fait haïti il faut que
j'étais coupé le pont et une sortie de
boîte j'étais complètement rincé le
tatoueur vingt dix la préfète a tous
quelqu'un qui dort super merci j'ai
envie en tout cas pour encore un beau
témoignage très beau témoignage dans
cette émission c'est d'être là